susanna felix says she was preparing
food for her children
when she heard gunshots then she saw her
neighbors running
confused and frightened she grabbed her
kids and also ran
it was the middle of the afternoon on
the 24th of march
the day the attack on palmer by an
isil-backed armed group
began i grabbed my children and we
started running
my husband was at work on the other side
of town i haven't heard from him since
march and his phone is switched off
the family is now staying with a
relative in pemba
the provincial capital but mamada isufu
could barely support his own wife and
children
now he has even more mouths to feed
we share the little we have with each
other i am the only one working
if i can find food to bring home i try
to do just that
sometimes we have nothing to eat at all
sometimes we eat one meal
once a day aid agencies estimate about
90
of those who reached pemba from palma
are staying with relatives
in recent months the small port city of
pemba in northern mozambique has been
overwhelmed
as thousands arrive on foot and on both
the population has grown
with some people saying it's doubled
many people are choosing to stay with
relatives
who already struggling economically
humanitarian workers do regular
follow-up visits offering psychological
support
and other assistance to those affected
by the violence but the needs are great
last month's attack on the gastric town
of palmer killed
dozens of people and displaced thousands
more
this is a crisis to which the world
needs to pay attention this is a crisis
that desperately needs for us as
humanitarians more funding
we've got a lot more to do here we've
got rising needs
and while there are many competing
crises around the world it is vital that
this one
gets attention these people have been
through so much they've been through
conflict they've been through cyclones
and they have urgent needs that we have
to help them meet carbohydrate province
where most of the major gas discoveries
have been made in recent years
has seen violence and instability since
2017
many families are constantly on the move
every time a town or village is attacked
they say going back to parma and any of
the other conflict zones
is no longer an option for them haru
mutasa al jazeera
pemba mozambique